RTL Matin Olivier bois
[Musique]
RTL ce matin et Marc féno le ministre de
l'Agriculture et de la souveraineté
alimentaire vous êtes avec nous en
studio vous a déjà salué monsieur le
ministre on va parler avec vous donc de
cette sécheresse exceptionnelle qui
frappe quasiment toute la France on sera
en ligne dans un instant avec des
agriculteurs qui nous ont appelés et qui
ont des questions directement à vous
poser mais avant cela une question sur
ce qui s'est passé cette nuit à
l'Assemblée nationale vous c'étiez
ministre délégué chargé des relations
avec le Parlement notre reporter Thomas
des prés nous a dit que les huissiers
n'avaient quasiment jamais vu une telle
une telle confusion une telle tension
les oppositions qui salit pour voter 500
millions pour les retraites contre la
vie du gouvernement le gouvernement qui
revient et qui fait annuler cet
amendement à deux heures du matin
comment vous allez tenir comme ça
comment vous allez gouverner comme ça
dans un tel climat pendant 5 ans d'abord
on a une majorité c'est relative qui
doit tenir le cap et qui veille à tenir
le cap à la fois budgétaire en dépense
et en
et puis deux ça dépend aussi de la
volonté qu'auront les oppositions
d'agir en responsabilité l'amendement
d'hier était un amendement de 500
millions d'euros portés d'ailleurs par
charge de Courson qui à l'époque était
plutôt un grand profondeur de la dépense
publique et qui appelait souvent à la
raison budgétaire on peut pas aligner
des dépenses sans se poser la question
des recettes ou des économies donc il y
a une forme de responsabilité parce
qu'elle avait été quand on est
parlementaire on est responsable des
deniers publics et on est responsables
devant la nation et devant les citoyens
à la fois des dépenses dont on a besoin
et en même temps de les maîtriser
suffisamment pour pas se retrouver avec
des difficultés sur la dette et le
déficit merci beaucoup pour votre
réponse et on va parler maintenant de la
situation de la sécheresse en toute la
France est quasiment concernée par les
mesures de restriction sur la
consommation d'eau il y a cette phrase
de Météo France qui dit que le mois de
juillet qu'on était en train de vivre
sera très probablement le plus sec
depuis 1958 d'abord est-ce qu'il y a un
plan d'urgence gouvernemental pour
passer l'été alors le plan d'urgence il
est d'abord sur la gestion il y a 89
département qui sont avec des mesures et
des restrictions d'eau de nature
diverses parfois restriction totale
parfois des restrictions plus relatives
en fonction des débits des cours d'eau
et des niveaux de nappes donc ça c'est
l'urgence immédiate c'est de gérer la
quantité d'eau qu'on a et donc et la
gérer en fonction des besoins des uns et
des autres le deuxième sujet ça va être
on est en train d'avaluer les choses on
a encore une nécessité d'aller plus loin
sur les dégâts en agriculture à la fois
sur les cultures céréalières et autres
et puis sur les effets sur les prairies
sur l'approvisionnement pour les
élevages et l'inquiétude qu'on appelle à
votre connaissance aujourd'hui sur les
cultures on est on vient de finir de la
moisson du blé en céréales c'est très
disparaître il y a des endroits où le la
moisson est plutôt correcte puisque le
blé avait bénéficié d'eau au moment où
il en avait besoin en avril mais si je
peux dire d'autres on a des pertes de
rendement de 20 à 30% globalement on
aura quand même une récolte correcte au
niveau national en revanche on a une
inquiétude sur les cultures qui sont le
maïs le tournesol et puis les prairies
principalement où là on voit bien que
certains j'ai pu faire qu'une récolte de
fourrage et donc là on va avoir un sujet
d'alimentation du bétail puisqu'il y a
un certain nombre d'animaux sont déjà
rentrés parce qu'il trouve plus rien
dans les prairies on commence déjà à les
alimenter avec du fourrage qui
normalement réservé à l'hiver mais à
propos du maïs Gautier Delon Bulgar je
vous lisez notre reporter qui est dans
la Vienne il était avec un pêcheur tout
à l'heure qui dit qu'il y a énormément
de dérogations précisément pour les
cultures de maïs et que c'est eux qui
pompent énormément d'eau et qui explique
que certaines rivières sont transformées
il nous l'a dit quasiment en chemin de
randonnée alors cette problématique ce
paradoxe il faut produire du blé mais
ils sont très consommateurs d'eau
paradoxe et tous l'équilibre que qu'on
doit qu'on doit gérer ce qu'on appelle
parfois les conflits d'usage de l'eau je
rappelle que la surface irriguée en
France c'est 5% de la surface agricole
donc au ramenant les choses à leur juste
mesure il y a des cultures qui sont plus
consommatrices d'eau alors il y a
travaillé sur des variétés qui sont
moins sensibles au stress hydrique et
qui ont moins besoin d'eau il y a des
territoires j'étais il y a une quinzaine
de jours en Charente ou on a réduit la
part du maïs mais le maïs il sert en
particulier l'alimentation animale donc
il faut aussi trouver parfois d'autres
cultures mais les agriculteurs depuis
longtemps sont engagés dans cette
évolution sur un certain nombre de
cultures moins indispensable
puisque depuis des années on a des
structure de capacité de
dépenses en eau si je peux dire qui est
en réduction et donc c'est ça que font
les agriculteurs mais en même temps
quand vous êtes éleveur vous avez quand
même un moment besoin de maïs dans un
certain nombre de régions alors monsieur
le ministre je vous dis nos auditeurs
nous ont appelé au 32
d'abord rock qui nous a appelé rock vous
avez 24 ans bonjour monsieur le ministre
bonjour agriculteurs dans le Rhône c'est
ça rock qu'est-ce que vous voulez dire
au ministre sur la situation vous êtes
en train de vivre aujourd'hui
qu'on a des restrictions d'eau sur sur
des cultures aujourd'hui notamment
maraîchères c'est c'est des cultures
qu'on aura en moins parce qu'ils vont
avoir souffert du manque d'eau à
l'automne et du coup ben on devrait
importer notre pays par exemple des sous
des betteraves des carottes des pommes
de terre alors que eux n'auront sûrement
pas eu de restriction d'eau donc
qu'est-ce qu'on vous demande de faire
comme effort et vous produisez quoi
d'ailleurs vous alors les productions
maraîchères les réflexions d'eau elles
poussaient surtout en limite d'horaires
c'est-à-dire que c'est de 21h à 9h le
matin et puis un jour sur deux ça dépend
des des
départements ou des rayons et vous
trouvez votre production va être
impactée pour le coup vous avec ce
manque d'eau toutes les plantes qui sont
en stade de Smith c'est le moment où
le besoin en eau est le plus délicat le
plus précis et on n'a pas toute la toute
la panoplie de ce qu'on de ce qu'on
voudrait faire alors Monsieur le
Ministre est-ce qu'on va manquer de
nourriture entre guillemets ou en tout
cas est-ce qu'on va devoir en emporter
plus et quelles conséquences ça pourrait
avoir sur les prix alors d'abord dans
tous les pays européens je parle avec
mes collègues européens il y a des
mesures de restriction d'eau parce qu'on
a des difficultés deuxième chose je sais
les efforts ça nécessite dans le milieu
agricole comme l'a dit
cette agriculteur et il a raison de dire
que ça peut poser des questions de
souveraineté c'est à dire on a besoin je
le répète en agriculture c'est pas une
affaire nouvelle c'est plus récemulaire
pour pas dire plus rémylinaire pour
cultiver on a besoin d'eux alors il y a
un sujet sur lequel on travaille issu
des travaux ce qu'on appelait le varen
de l'eau
on avait déjà des mesures où on avait
chaque année des problèmes d'eau le
barrage de Serre-Ponçon il a il a servi
à rien d'autre entre autres que de
permettre aux agriculteurs de bénéficier
d'eau dans les périodes où il y avait
dans le sud-est dans cette grande région
qui manque souvent d'eau d'avoir accès à
l'eau simplement on a des règlements
climatique qui fait que les événements
sont beaucoup plus violents et beaucoup
plus longs je parle sous l'oeil de Louis
Bodin on a des éléments beaucoup plus
récurrents et beaucoup plus récurrents
donc on a besoin de raisonner la
ressource en eau dans sa dans sa
capacité dans l'année en stocker quand
on a des exedos dans ce stocker un peu
une part pour après pouvoir la restituer
au moment où les agriculteurs on en ont
besoin donc c'est ça le travail qu'on a
à faire c'est d'essayer de de se
prémunir des épisodes comme ceux qu'on a
en ayant plus de réserves en eau et on
est à quel stade je précisément on
Gauthier de longs vulgaire d'ailleurs
dans la Vienne va nous parler d'un
projet justement précisément pour
stocker l'eau l'hiver et s'en servir
l'été on est prêt à le faire on est prêt
dans combien c'est l'issue des travaux
qui ont été menés à l'automne dernier
pour faire face à ces épisodes
dérèglement climatiques et de notamment
les épisodes de sécheresse il y a un
certain nombre de projets dans les
territoires l'idée c'est qu'on puisse
déployer ça à partir de l'année
prochaine pour qu'on puisse avoir des
premiers projets qui sortent de terre
c'est des projets sur lesquels une
grande vigilance du gouvernement par
ailleurs en terme de volume qui est
collecté et puis de d'impact
éventuellement sur l'environnement mais
je pense que c'est fait avec sérieux et
que désormais dans tous les pays du
monde ce sujet de l'accès à l'eau et de
la réserve en eau quand il y a beaucoup
d'eau qui tombent est un sujet qui est
sur la table et sur lequel nous
travaillons la semaine dernière le
directeur délégué de Suez était l'invité
RTL à votre place au micro Stéphane
Carpentier il disait que parmi les
solutions qui existaient c'était de
pouvoir autoriser les agriculteurs à
utiliser de l'eau déjà traitée de l'eau
qu'on a déjà utilisé tout un chacun la
France a moins le droit de le faire que
certains de nos voisins européens est-ce
que ça fait partie ça fait partie des
pistes en effet c'est l'eau que produit
de de l'eau de l'alimentation humaine si
je peux dire de l'eau qui est utilisée
par les êtres humains et c'est vrai
qu'on va essayer de regarder dans un
certain nombre de cas dans quelle mesure
on utiliser cette eau une fois qu'elle
est retraitéée parce que c'est un cercle
vertueux c'est au fond on recycle en
permanence et donc oui c'est un élément
c'est un des éléments qui sont la table
et aussi des Anglais qui sort de chez
nous tous les jours et finalement perdu
et s'en va dans la nature
il y a une partie qu'on peut
effectivement collecter et réutiliser ça
fait partie des pistes de travail
évidemment avec les conditions
sanitaires parce qu'on est un pays qui
aime beaucoup les normes et on a besoin
de le faire mais il y a des tas de pays
qui le font déjà et ça fait partie des
pistes en effet qui sont devant nous un
arc fais-nous ministre de l'Agriculture
vous êtes avec nous sur RTL on va
accueillir Philippe qui nous a appelé
également au 32 10 bonjour Philippe oui
bonjour vous êtes éleveur de brebis vous
à Montpellier quelle est la situation
dans votre exploitation dans votre ferme
oui je suis éleveur de brebis en Lozère
notre situation elle est simple depuis
le 1er janvier on n'a pas 200 mm d'eau
donc on est sans parler de l'eau pour
pour les champs il y a plus d'eau pour
faire avoir
c'est une situation inédite honnêtement
je pense qu'on n'a jamais vu ça mais
honnêtement je vais vous le dire c'est
pas le problème parce que le sécheresse
de notre métier en élevage ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on tâche d'avoir du stock un
peu de stock d'avance pour prévenir
justement nécessaire
aujourd'hui
pour quand il arrive une période
sécheresse sauf qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui
monsieur monsieur le ministre le gasoil
je le payais 7-600 700 euros tonnes je
paye 1400 l'engrais il a triplé
je vous parle pas de tout le reste chez
moi c'est 60000 euros 60000 euros de
trésorerie à sortir je ne les ai pas
comment je fais je stocke les factures
j'espère que les factures et encore les
fournisseurs me font confiance
j'ai peur
j'ai plus peur de ça
que de la sécheresse Philippe le
ministre vous répondre évidemment quand
vous entendez on a entendu sur RTL
notamment des pêcheurs qui disent c'est
à cause de l'agriculture que les les
rivières sont à sec parce qu'ils
utilisent trop d'eau et l'irrigation est
trop forte qu'est-ce que vous vous
répondez à ça
c'est que dans peut-être trois mois on
va avoir 10 20 cm d'eau par jour et elle
va se barrer l'eau elle va tout arracher
et on est incapable à stocker vous savez
ce qu'on va faire nous ici dans notre
région on va aller chercher la la bouffe
pour nos animaux en Espagne vous savez
en Espagne c'est je crois que c'est un
peu chaud et sec sauf que eux ils ont
travaillé sur l'eau ils récupèrent les
Pyrénées
de Philippe monsieur le ministre
agriculture le système fonctionne pas en
France visiblement il y a des il y a un
problème si vous permettez il y a deux
sujets il y a le sujet qui a été évoqué
du stockage de loge rencontré d'ailleurs
les élus auxériens les représentants du
monde agricole hier pour évoquer cette
question et pour voir avec eux les
solutions d'abord on a un sujet immédiat
c'est un sujet qui a été évoqué c'est un
sujet très
et donc faut regarder au travers des pré
garantis par l'état d'un certain nombre
de dispositifs de dialogues avec les
banques comment on fait en sorte que les
agriculteurs puissent aujourd'hui
s'approvisionner en fourrage en
alimentation du bétail parce
qu'effectivement ils ont besoin dès à
présent de pouvoir le faire or et un
certain nombre de dispositifs qui
n'arrive qu'un peu plus tard dans la
saison et donc on a besoin dès à présent
de d'alléger les trésories des
agriculteurs pour leur permettre
d'accéder simplement à l'alimentation
animale et puis le deuxième sujet on est
en Lozère 200 mm la Lozère c'est 1700 mm
d'eau qui tombent chaque année donc on a
voyait la mesure du déficit ça veut dire
qu'il devrait en tomber 1500 mm d'ici la
fin de l'année et donc c'est en cela que
je me suis a raison il faut regarder ce
qu'on peut capter d'une partie de cette
eau 1700 mm la moyenne nationale je
crois que c'est 800 oui
c'est quand même des ouvrages qu'il faut
construire donc je me livrerai pas à la
démagogie pour dire que ça va très vite
mais en tout cas on est ça sera un peu
facile vous avez raison mais sur le
moyen ce sera pas face c'est pas facile
mais c'est effectivement pas facile mais
sur le moyen terme effectivement il faut
se poser la question c'est vrai qu'il y
a un certain nombre de pays c'est une
surprise si c'est les pays
méditerranéens comme les Espagnols qui
ont déjà posé ces questions là il faut
qu'on les pose que désormais on a
l'équation qui est posée désormais il
faut faire les ouvrages et on est on est
face au même problème que les pays plus
au sud que nous et c'est ça ne va pas
changer oui oui qu'est-ce que vous
voulez ajouter que les quantités de
pluie qui tombent sur la France sont
toujours les mêmes donc effectivement
c'est juste une gestion et une façon de
retenir ou d'utiliser cette eau qui doit
évoluer il faut changer
les mêmes sauf peut-être près de la
Méditerranée c'est pas le même lieu
effectivement c'est pas le même rythme
chaque année mais c'est la même quantité
et donc c'est le travail qu'on a à faire
de réguler pour pouvoir en disposer
quand on en a besoin comme des périodes
comme celle-là merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre Marc phénoménaliste de la
culture